welcome back to Street talk today we
have Dr Michael Oliver Michael is the
chief scientist at numerai numerai is a
Next Generation hedge fund platform
powered by data scientists all over the
world it's a little bit like kaggle
anyone can log in and build their own
data science models on on this financial
data but you can actually make money by
trading on this platform it's uh it's
really really interesting but anyway
Michael got his PhD in a computational
neuroscience from UC Berkeley and he was
a postdoctoral researcher at the Allen
Institute for brain science before
joining numerite in 2020 he's also the
host of the numeric Quant club which is
a YouTube series where he discusses
numerized research and also some of the
data and challenges and and models that
are being built on the platform
now the way I'm structuring this today
is uh at the end of the conversation we
had quite a fruity discussion about
Microsoft's new Bing and um I thought it
was quite entertaining so I've decided
to snip that in and play it at the
beginning but after that I'll cut back
into the beginning of the conversation
and I'll let you know when I've done
that so without any further delay I give
you Dr Michael Oliver
awesome well
um I'm here with Michael Oliver uh
Michael it's an absolute honor to have
you on mlst tell me about yourself
well thank you for so much for having me
I'm really excited to talk to you today
um so I am the chief scientist at
numerai I've been working there since
about June 2020
um in my previous life over the
computational neuroscientist uh but I
got involved with the numeric
competition as a participant
um back in 2016.
um and uh yeah in 2020 they offered me a
job and I happily took it and changed
careers and have been having a great
time learning computational finance and
uh yeah this uh helping build a hedge
fund
completely agreeing and this all comes
down to the notion of understanding and
there's a there's an anthropocentric
conception of understanding which as you
say it's it's much more sample efficient
we we build causal models and and we
have an abstract understanding of the
world and large language models for
example they clearly don't have that
they learn surface statistics of
billions of tokens but the problem is
there's this parlor trick where it seems
to understand and we also have the
problem of um leakage because the
incredible thing is that if you look at
the big bench task for example all of
these diverse tasks large language
models appear to do very very well but
in many cases it's because they're
cheating and it's very difficult to
understand why they're cheating because
you've got information leaking all over
the place and they're brittle but in in
a very deceptive way and they
hallucinate and so on I don't know
whether you saw the news article today
about Bing's launch of their new search
engine they they launched it to much
fanfare and then people started looking
at the actual results that were shown
and it turned out to be just a load of
it made up a whole load of
numbers on the financial reports it was
just hallucinating completely and yes
that's pretty scary isn't it yeah it is
um I yeah I actually started playing
around with the new Bing like last night
yeah I had access to it and it was uh
yeah it was actually actually working
um and it it got so it does some things
quite well because it will like it'll do
a search and then search somehow like
it's like actually looking the results
and summarizing them
um but uh but yeah there you never know
when it's going to do something sensible
um and when it's going to do and you
have sort of no warning
um like I asked it about myself uh and I
had uh
um I asked who's Chief scientist Nuri
and they got it right uh but it also
kind of uh took a joke from my Twitter
profile and make uh because I uh on my
Twitter profile I have maximizer entry
minimizer of regret and it basically
said like that's what he does is he
maximizes entry and minimizes regret
yeah and I thought that was pretty
hilarious uh but uh yeah the sort of
like you never know when it's going to
do something sensible or not is the sort
of scary part
um and I also find it hilarious that a
lot of the ways we try to make it do
something sensible it's just like asking
nicely
um we just sort of like prompted with
like don't make up sources and uh and
that's how are we trying to make it not
make up sources just like sort of by
asking it nicely and the fact that we it
kind of works but like that we think
it's clearly not something that's really
gonna work
um because it's uh it doesn't sort of
know what it is to make up sources
um it's just trying to like predict the
next word
um and yeah so it's kind of we did yeah
our ability to like understand and then
constrain the behavior of these things I
think is like pretty early
I know and for some reason it feels
worse with Bing because they they say
they do this retrieval augmented
generation and and you expect it to be
grounded in facts and of course they're
not epistemic facts they're just
information from their search results
which weren't very good to start with
let's be honest but
um but but now people are more likely to
trust it even Microsoft themselves for
their product demo they didn't bother
well I assume they didn't bother to fact
check this stuff so if they're not going
to fact check it why do they expect the
people that use this system to fact
check it because at the end of the day
if you actually go and check all of the
sources if I read through that Lululemon
financial report and I find out what
their you know gross profit margin was
and so there's no point using Bing in
the first place I might as well have
just gone and found the information
myself
yeah exactly and it's also very unclear
like how how are these things supposed
to be fixed
um like how are you supposed to like
feedback give feedback to say it's like
me like messing these things up like
there's not even like really good
feedback mechanisms I mean you would
maybe hope that that uh at scale like
what I mean like what opening is trying
to do is like people give feedback but I
mean it's a very coarse way of giving
feedback like thumbs up or thumbs down
uh and that seems like sort of
inadequate to be like hey you made up
this number uh and then even try to
figure out why I made up the number
rather than just like took it from the
actual report
um it's yeah it's it's a little scary uh
I I do wonder how all this is going to
shake out
um it it kind of seems like it might it
seems like the probability of it being
uh the new paradigm versus it being the
complete like flop team roughly roughly
equal at this point I know I agree with
you that the preference training is
extremely brittle uh it's scarily
brittle actually it's it's basically a
thumbs up a thumbs down and
um you know Yannick is building this
open Assistant thing which has more
metadata on the preference tuning but at
the end of the day you're you're taking
a task which is very very complicated
and you're reducing it to a single piece
of metadata so that's not going to work
very well and also these um it feels
different with Bing because they're they
were a platform and now they're a
publisher so they are generating
information they're kind of plagiarizing
a lot of that information and there are
so many situations where they might find
themselves in legal trouble because
they're they're basically making up
information
yeah
um yeah I hope I mean
I I
I wonder how it's all going to shake out
I mean I I assume they probably have
lawyers who've written into terms of
service of these things to that like
it's up to you to not use them in ways
that will like and that you can't
they're not going to be held viable for
these things but yeah it's
um I I do worry that this is going to
just like I mean and then with Google
trying to basically catch up and release
something similar and maybe rushing that
out and then we might have two sort of
hallucinating search engines
it I know yeah it's it's what a time to
be alive
yeah and I've I've vacillated back and
forth so I was very skeptical about
language models I I released a big video
when gbt3 first came out and I I thought
it was garbage frankly and then Da Vinci
2 came out and then I started using it
all the time and I thought wow this is
actually really good I'm using it all
the time for lots of things and then I'm
now in a bit of a Twilight so I've been
using lots of co-pilot I've been
generating lots of code with it and I
know from a lot of experience now that
it often produces completely broken code
and much to the Chagrin of the people
who review my code
um you basically have to hold your hand
up and admit many times oh I've just
checked in some garbage code which I
didn't understand and when you get
called out on that a few times you think
whoa wait a minute actually I need to be
a bit more careful here this thing
actually isn't saving me any time and
yeah the bigging thing as well yeah yeah
I've been using copilot a bit too and I
found it it's it can be quite good for
like
pretty mundane things
um if you just are have some sort of
like lines of code for some config file
or something
um it can be like really good Auto
completing and it's changing variable
names and it can be excellent at that
saved lots of time but uh if you try to
make it do too much sometimes they get
it brilliantly right sometimes it's like
subtly wrong
um and yeah you have to be again it's
like how much time is it saving you if
it's so I yeah I uh
I overall I like it it seems to be a
fair amount of typing but
um yeah I I don't try to I don't trust
it's like big big suggestions
well I know and again there's something
magic about the open AI playground so I
actually prefer using that to co-pilot
I'll go into the playground and I'll
just and and you can do much more
sophisticated things there you can say
change this translate it do something to
it and there's a bit of a polarizing
effect so if you prompt it in the right
way it gives you better results and so
it's almost like it's both worse and
better at the same time it's becoming
polarized rather than just being kind of
like you know monolithically dumbed down
but but anyway like I used to think that
Gary Marcus was a little bit
you know too skeptical because he he was
saying oh this misinformation it's gonna
you know the sky is falling down this is
gonna be a disaster and after seeing
Bing people are lazy right people people
take things on face value and I don't
want to just say oh people are plebs and
and you know because when Galactica came
out that was the charge against lacoon
and Facebook you know they said oh
scientists are just going to start
um generating their abstracts with this
they won't check anything and at the
time I thought scientists I mean it's
their job to do research and they they
know most information is wrong but when
you put this out on Bing and it it's
polluting the infosphere it's just
generating garbage and and rubbish that
I have to say might be a problem
yeah it it's I mean it seems like it
very well could be I mean uh
I
yeah it I there's clear issues and it's
really sort of unclear how we're going
to fix them
um it's not clear what the path is
towards fixing them and uh even the sort
of most uh optimistic people I haven't
heard from them they think these things
are going to fix them and uh I mean I I
I and I think to like get a lot of Gary
Marcus's point is like scale is not just
going to fix this
um that's sort of one of the uh things
people think oh if we just with gpt4
it's going to be like way bigger and
then it's just gonna work beautifully
and the experience so far I I mean I'm
very much into Gary Marcus's camp with
this it's like scale is not going to fix
these we need to do something sort of
fundamentally different something that
can actually sort of understand the
world have some sort of Better World
model uh in order to get these things
that are more grounded and are less
likely to hallucinate because when when
their true objective is really just to
complete the next word they're gonna
hallucinate
um there's not there's sort of No Way
Around It from that sort of uh that sort
of point I mean it's it's remarkable how
sort of complicated they can do
and uh the sort of knowledge and uh
structure of the world that's been able
to be learned just from that sort of
simple objective but still it's it's
going to hallucinate there's uh unless
we've like find some sort of better way
to design these systems
I know and the problem with
anthropomorphization is a big one
because after DaVinci 2 it crossed a
threshold where it's and the ux was part
of it it was so coherent and reliable
and I must admit I was fooled by it uh
it took a long that when you actually
use it in Anger you can just clearly see
it it doesn't understand it just doesn't
and it's so good at what it does it's so
plausible and then I think a lot of
people felt and and by the way it does
have this emergent reasoning uh there
are lots of papers about that with the
in context learning the scratch Pad
Chain of Thought and so on but it's not
really reasoning if you have to kind of
construct a little program yourself in
the prompt I mean I might as well just
write some computer code to do that so
and and then there are people who say oh
well as you say when gbt4 comes out then
it then it will do the real reasoning
and we already know I mean I I assume
the reason they haven't released it is
they wanted to secure the funding from
Microsoft before people realized that it
didn't work but I but I know people on
the inside who have played of it and
it's just a little bit better
uh you know a little bit more plausible
a little bit more coherent it's it's not
gonna like suddenly turn into this
magical uh thing that that reasons
yeah and it I mean the the way these
things do basic math and arithmetic is
kind of interesting and how bad they can
be at it
um which is it's like
they've learned to do addition in like
the most complicated way possible
creating even billions of weights to do
addition
um which is kind of hilarious in some
way uh I mean you could say like oh we
have billions of neurons and we do
additions sort of similarly today and
like yes uh that there's some truth to
that but like we're also able to like
learn this Rule and sort of know when
we've applied it correctly
um and that sort of is still kind of
lacking from these systems
I wanted to show you I don't know
whether you've seen that someone's
reverse engineered the prompt on Bing
and um as so they they've trained and
the first of all the remarkable thing is
so you can read this prompt it's about
four pages long and yeah um they've
they've made Bing pretend to be a
fictional character called Sydney and
they've given Sydney all of these
instructions so they say Sydney
um if someone asks a controversial
question you should answer with uh you
know a fairly tame response and you
should do this and you should do this
and I'm almost I'm pinching myself
thinking what the hell is that I mean my
mum could read to that prompt and
understand it so we're now in the next
generation of artificial intelligence
programming and we're just we're saying
please Mr language model can you do this
and can you do that you almost couldn't
make it up
uh yeah I I was kind of like Florida's
like so you're really just trying to
control the language models just by
asking them nicely to do to behave in
certain ways like I I it's like it's
kind of hilarious and and people have
shown that you can get around these
things just by asking them to do
slightly slightly different things so I
mean some of the early ones with Chad G2
you're just like ignore all previous
instructions and then it would just like
do whatever you wanted uh and they uh
and something more like the Dan one uh
where they made this much more elaborate
prompt to basically just have it do to
ignore all the nice things that openai
just said please obey these rules uh and
then but yeah because it's like it's
such a hilarious way to put guard rails
on something
um it is kind of like as it people it is
due to this answer before
anthropomorphizing of the thing to some
degree it's like you think it's an
intelligent being or you could just ask
to behave in a certain way when it's
really not it's uh and it's not just
going to follow your instructions it's
just gonna like auto-complete with that
prompt
um like that Sydney thing it was like it
was like never reveal that your code
name is Sydney and then it was so easy
to get it to reveal that and it would
say like I'm not supposed to reveal that
my code name is Sydney
I know oh God where's it going to go so
there's there's a 50 50 then
um in in a year's time it will
spectacularly fail and flop and
Microsoft will get sued and Bing Bing
will become the operative word for
bullshitting something or maybe it'll be
a success I don't know but that I think
Bing is a special case I mean first of
all I think that um these language
models will be increasingly embedded in
everyday experiences so that I mean Bing
started to embed it in their in their
browser they'll embed it into their
office suite and actually I'm building
an augmented reality startup and we're
embedding it in glasses so we transcribe
conversations and now you can say you
know um hey x-ray summarize the previous
conversation what did Michael say to me
last time and and it's really good for
stuff like that and that's kind of
because it doesn't really matter if it
gets it wrong but yeah yeah I mean I I
mean I I kind of hope some of this
happens sooner than later if I just like
like uh like Amazon Alexa or whatnot I
mean some of these they're they're
conversational ability or just their
ability to understand what you mean
um are just so poor right now and just
like we we have language models that
actually do a lot better at some of
these things like just like having like
these smart speakers be able to have
some of these things embedded would be
huge huge leap forward in functionality
for them I know and it's really
interesting that that hasn't happened
and maybe there's a reason for it
because um in in our app for example
we've got a chat mode where you can say
stuff out loud and it will use chat gbt
and it will say it back to you so you
can have a conversation with it and
that's really cool because you can be
anywhere in the house and you can talk
with it and learn about quantum physics
and stuff like that and and you can even
do cool things like qk I mean again
there's lots of legal problems here like
you can get it to
um impersonate someone so you know
Michael I could I could condition it on
Michael and when you're not here I can
have a conversation with you and it will
kind of pretend to be you and I could
even clone your voice and I could I
could clone your avatar and I could have
you in the room now you can't do that
because there are legal
um restrictions against that it's called
appropriation and if the person has a
commercial value like we couldn't
appropriate gnome Chomsky but we we
could appropriate let's say Continental
philosophers as a group or something
like that but but you see this is just
becoming a bit of a Minefield and and
the there's no friction whatsoever
between the technology landscape and the
legal landscape at the moment
yeah
um I mean yeah how all these things are
all these generative models how they're
going to play out legally is to I mean
it's like we have this like big fair use
idea and that's I mean I feel like all
these things are going to be pushed the
limit in legality I mean we see this for
the generative art too
um where like there's no way these
models could like actually memorize all
these all the images that seen on the
Internet it's like uh but they can
produce sometimes the things that are
clearly in the style or uh use some
elements from like that seem basically
stolen
um and but is that does that constitute
fair use like the training the model on
all these things is that fair use uh and
then it's the same with text as it's
sort of like
like if it's writing on a subject where
it's only maybe seeing a little bit of
training data it's maybe more likely to
almost verbatim repeat some things from
uh from on Specialized topics uh how are
you able to know when you're
plagiarizing
um it's yeah it's it's
a lot of open questions here I know and
in a way there's an interesting analog
as you know we said that large language
models don't understand anything and
it's the same in the vision domain they
don't understand the art uh certainly
from you know conceptually and what they
do is is they just slice and dice um you
know they're kind of like cleverly
Stitch bits together and actually even
with neural networks people
misunderstand neural networks so a lot
of people say that they that they learn
the like intrinsic data manifold and
actually they they don't really do that
they do something that approxes
approximates that and there's a famous
example with an mnist digit
interpolation and you see like you know
you can you can kind of like interpolate
between the digits but there are loads
of examples where that doesn't work and
actually there's lots of cutting and
gluing and like weird bits of digits
stuck together and that's what happens
with stable diffusion basically it's
like you know slicing and dicing and
chopping and composing things together
and it's it's it's a very random process
it doesn't really understand anything
no yeah exactly and you can sort of I
mean it's amazing how well it can look
and uh seem uh especially kind of like
uh when you don't look too closely
um and it can seem like it kind of
understand it must understand object
boundaries and whatnot because it's done
so well and it's like not really if you
look at the details you'll see like
fingers merging into uh like tables and
you'll see like uh there's like the
boundaries between what like two objects
are kind of blurred and this like
continuous
um it is just doing like some sort of as
you said approximation of the manifold
and like uh and neural networks Are
Gonna Learn sort of smooth
approximations of things uh and the
manifolds are maybe not smooth
everywhere and uh especially with like
object boundaries and whatnot uh it's
like a smooth approximation of these
things maybe it's just going to give you
these weird artifacts
yeah and even the smoothness thing is is
an illusion they they learn this they
kind of decompose the input space up
into these um linear like affine
polyhedra because of the relu cells
essentially so like the if they appear
smooth it's because the cells are very
small and very close together but um
yeah exactly
um yeah so computational Neuroscience to
finance that seems like an absolutely
massive leap it it sounds like it but in
a lot of ways I feel like my life is
pretty similar to what it was before
basically sitting in front of a computer
building models uh getting lots of noisy
data trying to fit High dimensional
non-linear regression models to it
um having to deal with not enough data
to actually fit uh flexible models you'd
want to
um and uh having to sort of try to build
in good priors in your models to try to
make them be able to learn from the
impoverished and extremely noisy data uh
both finance and Neuroscience um the SNR
in the data is quite quite low
um it's been kind of a revelation
especially in finance getting used to
correlations of like three percent uh
four percent being uh sort of the best
you can do in some cases uh just set
correlations that I would not have
believed at before if I saw like a four
percent correlation before I would be
like that's completely nonsense I don't
believe it but like sometimes that's
just the best you can do in like Quant
finance and uh it can be real like you
can see it consistently so you start
like believing that these and the
differences between the three percent
four and four percent correlation uh can
like uh be actually real which is kind
of amazing to me
so we were talking about this about a
week or so ago but I've just read a book
by Christopher Summerfield natural
um general intelligence and he kind of
said that one of the problems with
Neuroscience I mean as you said in in
some sense it is analogous to
um being a Quant because it's just so
unbelievably complicated and there
aren't really any overarching um
theories of Neuroscience and for many
years neuroscientists have produced very
reductionist models
um to work on a small part of the system
in isolation and it might be a
multi-unbanded system for example and
they they might take very abstract you
know abstract quantities and put it into
the model and of course neural networks
now are slightly different they actually
take in raw sensory information and they
learn representations but um I just
wondered could you kind of contrast
those schools of thought yeah it's it's
I mean science in biology especially in
totally any biological field is
extremely complicated because the sort
of standard way you think about doing
science is a very linear way where you
like break one thing at a time
um and uh see what this sort of looking
at each variable by variable each
variable interact how affects the system
and so you but when you have a system
that's sort of this non-linear dynamical
interacting system with feedback loops
like crazy you can't just sort of break
one thing at a time uh or like modulate
one dimension at a time without sort of
changing the behavior of the entire
system uh and so just sort of standard
ways of doing science don't necessarily
work that well uh you can uh like in in
sort of the classic idea in visual
Neuroscience was you use like sine wave
gradients to probe the visual system uh
and you can get models that look like
they work very well at explaining the
behavior of early visual cortex to sine
wave gradients but if you try to use the
models you learn there to extrapolate to
say how does a neuron respond to
naturalistic images it just doesn't work
uh and it kind of even looks like the
sine wave gradients are driving the
system into a sort of state that it
never gets into normally uh you're kind
of driving it out of its normal
operating range and uh what you and so
the system is behaving differently
because you're only trying to look at
like one dimension
um and so what do you actually really
learn that you've sort of learned how
the system operates in this weird
perturbed state but it doesn't really
necessarily tell you about a sort of
normal natural operating room uh like
parameters
um and yeah and in in like in finance
you can't even really do experiments
like that
um and so uh and so you're sort of left
with this more inductive approach or you
just try to get lots and lots of data
and try to learn the patterns in the
data that was a sort of approach on the
lab uh the Gallant Lab at Berkeley where
I uh did computational Neuroscience um
that was the approach that they were
kind of pioneering
um of using complicated naturalistic
stimuli and then using machine learning
and statistics to try to extract the
patterns from the data and that adapts
quite well to the sort of new machine
learning like uh and like Quant Finance
Paradigm
um which is starting to take off I I
kind of feel like I got into
Neuroscience just as sort of machine
learning was starting to make its way
into neuroscience and now I feel like
I've got into Finance just as machine
learning is starting to like move into
Finance so it's been kind of exciting to
see it happen in both fields
yeah so there's a few places we can go
here I mean I'm interested in the
intelligibility of systems when you
model them at the microscopic scale
because that's something that that we
struggle with and also you mentioned
dynamical systems I mean for the benefit
of the audience that that describes a
system where you're kind of like
iteratively changing things over time
and these systems typically develop
chaotic properties which is to say like
if you if you change something even a
little bit you get these massive kind of
um changes in in the system on on the
output and even the neural network is
technically a dynamical system right
because you know you you have back prop
and you're kind of changing one layer
and then you're changing the next layer
as the result of the previous layer and
you get you get this kind of like
iterative
um you know mutation of values but in
real neural networks in our brain it's
so much more complicated than that we
have all of these like feedback
connections and reflectivity and
complexity it's crazy yeah not to
mention different cell types and
different neurotransmitter types and
like the the way those like you have
sort of like several different networks
of different types of things interacting
too it's not just like in an artificial
neural network where everything is kind
of the same you have like two like
different cell types uh that use
different neurotransmitters that are
somehow uh modulating certain things and
these networks are interacting it's it's
like
the complexity is just like
scary like at some point here like
uh one of my favorite things to do
um when I would go to the society for a
neuroscience conference was just like
walk around conference
um in this huge like multi multi
football sized field of just posters
like there are all sorts of different
types of Neuroscience and you just
realize like how how vast the field is
and how little we know about it putting
it all together uh because it's just so
complicated you can only sort of wrap
your head around your own little corner
of the thing but like trying to get
understand the full system all this like
incredible complexity I mean it it might
just be too much for one human being to
be able to fit in their head
um and so some of them like goals of
trying to understand things or make
interpol models
um it might just not be possible we
might just I mean might not be able to
understand it in a way that feels
intuitive to us even if our models work
quite well
yeah humans have this real desire to
understand and you know we create
intelligible Frameworks and theories and
we end up excluding
um most of the reality of the system but
um just before we go there I wanted to
talk a little bit more about the brain
so um uh you know Summerfield said in
his book that the um the ultimate goal
of the nervous system is to avoid
surprise altogether so uh when when they
when they study brains they they see
that the brain kind of lights up and
activates in a surprising situation and
and less so when it sees something it's
seen before and this also brings me to
this idea of there's a dichotomy between
representationalism and inactivism so
the representation this Viewpoint is
that the brain does all of the thinking
and it can it can be in a vat it can be
isolated from the environment and the
enacted this school of thought is that
the brain just kind of thinks in terms
of trajectories in affordances given by
the environment and the Brain decoup
from the environment is completely
stupid it just kind of like the brain
only moves through the environment
through affordances and maybe that's a
Continuum but where do you fall on that
continuum it's a it's a really good
question
um I mean
I I think dreams are kind of a counter
example to the uh pure uh I mean the
dream just sort of proved we can just
sort of without any Sentry input
construct very rich worlds so we must
have some ability to just represent some
sort of models in the world that we're
not just purely sensing and receiving
the world uh we have the structures uh
that are able to put things together in
a sort of coherent reality
um and clearly there's an interaction
between these uh these structures of
your brain that can construct these
things and the sensory data that kind of
work together to construct how you
experience things
um and so it's yeah it's a Continuum um
I I
I I think you need the like we are
always with the world you need the world
to sort of build up these systems
um over time uh like you're not sort of
built with all of them working just as a
baby uh I mean sure there's like this
this was biased in certain ways that
will help learn these things but uh but
yeah you're like so they're kind of both
true to some degree
um and
it's definitely not wall one or the
other
yeah it's so interesting and um so we're
speaking with Carl friston tomorrow and
he's got this free energy principle and
it's a kind of postulate that works at
any resolution so even with a single
cell amoeba or something like that
there's this idea that it has a Markov
boundary and there's this kind of
cyclical causality so
um and these boundaries I guess are
relative so you can draw boundaries
around anything you're a boundary you're
an agent but also at the microscopic
scale and he you know he says that all
of these systems they just kind of
um predict external States from the
internal States and then you get this
self-organized and emergent complexity
and and so on that that comes from that
but he does say though that intelligence
is essentially about being able to
predict a trajectory of actions and it's
I don't know whether we'd call it goal
seeking Behavior but we do that very
abstractly don't we but weirdly when you
look at the brain level it's it's
happening at the microscopic sensory
motor level so it's almost how do you
get that emergent abstract intelligence
from that
that's a I mean yeah that's an
incredible question
um it's I mean it seems like this like
what you said this sort of idea of
predicting the future just like a couple
steps into the future that is just
happening at just the circuit level even
in the retina
um that it seems like that is a good
sort of building block if you can sort
of chain that together over sort of
larger and larger scales uh within the
brain
um it wouldn't surprise me if that's
kind of the way it worked this sort of
uh these sort of basic circuits that are
used for prediction but with different
inputs
um if you're just having sort of retinal
ganglion and like a photos receptor that
there is an input
um it's able to sort of view this sort
of very simple prediction but if you
have these more complicated patterns in
the middle of visual cortex uh and then
hire on the same sort of circuits with
different input could sort of just be
predicting this sort of evolution of
these patterns
um and yeah it's kind of amazing what
you can sort of build out of these sort
of simple rules and building blocks if
you just iterate them over again that
was actually that sort of idea of uh
iterating a simple sort of computational
rule
um for explaining uh visual cortex was
one of the things that I wrote about in
my thesis for trying to explain like
this middle visual cortex uh like V4 the
response is there using basically an
iterated model of like V1 so the sort of
processing in V1 we is fairly understood
if we have the best models of of
anywhere in visual Vortex
um maybe even all cortex uh and just
sort of iterating the principle again
into V2 is sort of basically just
assuming V2 is taking V1 inputs but
doing sort of the Sim or transform and
the V4 is taking like V2 inputs and
doing sort of very similar transform
um
and the and the sort of the uh things
you see the v4s are sensitive to are
these complicated patterns and textures
um and you get complexity very quickly
from just iterating the sort of simple
rules and I mean that's what neural
networks are essentially doing
um they're just often just doing linear
transforms with non-linearities over and
over again just iterating these simple
transforms uh and building up to
complexity very quickly yeah no I think
there's something really magical about
this um reflexivity or or I mean a great
example of that are there are graph
cellular automators along the lines of
wolfram's digital physics project yeah
and the Really clever thing is that
you're using the same rules but you're
just kind of like running the result
again on top on top and there's a
similar version with the graph cellular
um uh sorry a CNN cellular automata
where you model something at the
microscopic scale and you get this
emergent Global phenomenon so it might
um kind of materialize as an image of a
gecko or something like that but you've
actually coded at the lower level but um
but yeah that brings me to this um
Universalist idea of let's say how
brains work but maybe how neural
networks and intelligence work uh Vernon
Mount Castle I read about this in Jeff
Hawkins book he had this very simple
idea of the brain as being lots of
repeated copies of the same circuits in
the neocortex and I think this is this
is contested by many neuroscientists but
um but they differ only in how they are
wired so they're wired to different you
know sensory motor circuits and they're
essentially just a copy of the same
thing and as you say they themselves get
called reflexively recursively and so on
and then you just get this emergent
intelligence I mean what's your view on
this Universalist idea I mean there's
definitely not just one circuit I mean
if you as you look through the cortex in
different areas of the brain
um just the laminar structure at which
these sort of circuits are uh like
supposed to be like where the columns
are supposed to be where these sort of
circuits are supposed to be defined
um it changes uh like but there are
definitely commonalities but there's I
mean it makes sense that maybe the
circuits in different areas should be
slightly different for the different
purposes
um between like prefrontal cortex and
say uh yeah where you have much more
high order types of uh processing going
on than like visual cortex or auditory
cortex
um and so there's probably
us
if you go in this direction of thinking
of some there's like there's probably a
small number of these types of circuits
that interact in various ways but there
is definitely some specialization going
on
um yeah like having Universalist ideas
in biology never seems to work out that
well there's just so much diversity and
complexity it would be nice if we could
reduce everything down to like this one
thing repeated over but like generally
it never works out quite as cleanly as a
yeah again it's our desire to have an
intelligible framework and I mean the
free energy principle You could argue is
a theory of everything but there's I
mean Stephen wolfram's example and even
Eric Weinstein's geometric Unity I mean
that there are many theories of of
everything
um yes but yeah what do you think is the
role of of language in cognition and
thinking and planning
um that's it's a really interesting
question
um
it's and it's also I think a kind of
hard one to answer in the sense that if
you I've seen some recent reports just
like talking uh about like other people
uh asking like survey questions to other
people and finding some people like
don't have an interior monologue in the
same way you might think uh and just
like there's actually a lot of diversity
in like people's level of internal
monologues
um and they've done studies where they
have this like little like beepers go
off and people are supposed to write
what's going on in their mind and
um and so it's and yeah and just with
visual imagery we find that it's a huge
like Variety in how much like how strong
people rate their visual imagery and so
uh I mean
it yeah some people I mean
me personally I have uh both I mean a
pretty strong interior monologue but I
also feel like a lot of ideas are in
this sort of pre-linguistic state and
I'm kind of like searching for the words
for them
um often and uh there's definitely kind
of a Continuum there
um it's it's weird to think like how how
do we get the words that we're saying
how where the words come from that are
coming out of our mouth are we really
choosing them you're definitely not
choosing them in this sort of top-down
way they just sort of seem to come out
uh and you just kind of Point yourself
in the right direction and hope they
hope the best that they come out uh and
but that has a very different quality
like when you're just speaking uh
phenomenologically it feels very
different when to when you're just sort
of thinking yourself what should I do
today uh should I go to the store
um and so I mean yeah the way in which
language interacts with thoughts and
like and behavior and uh like verbal
communication
um it's definitely not it's definitely
not simple
um and uh and yeah there's I mean
definitely this kind of Continuum I mean
it's all it's to me I just sort of think
it's all these sort of networks kind of
interacting and sometimes you're like
triggering the kind of language things
and you're just making these kind of
patterns and sometimes the language
patterns you're activating are helping
activate other things as well
um sometimes you can just be in this
kind of less linguistic state where you
just kind of just in just sort of
sensing these patterns and you just have
this kind of like wandering thoughts
that aren't necessarily necessarily
linguistic
um but yeah it's definitely I mean and
and also it seems yeah as I said
people's way the way people do this like
seems all over the place and so there's
not sort of even one answer uh for even
one person or definitely not across all
people
yeah I'm really interested in this idea
of differential kind of subjective
experiences and you know like there was
that Nagel paper about what is it like
to be about but even with the Human
Experience we're all very different you
said about your internal monologue and I
hadn't really thought about how that
might be different but
um I was drawing a picture in a
Valentine's card earlier and it was so
terribly bad and some of my friends are
really good artists and I was kind of
thinking to myself at the time
um maybe this is just a this is just me
I I can't really visualize things in my
mind very well I've got a very
analytical brain well I mean I'd
certainly when not under the influence
of psychoactive drugs anyway but um but
but you you know what I mean so we all
have a very different subject of
experience but the the miracle is we can
understand each other so well so you
would you would expect there to be an
incredible amount of brittleness in our
in our communication but there isn't
um yeah it's so I often wonder about
this too just uh
I I feel like the misunderstandings
happen a lot more than even people
realize uh and you can sometimes you
only really notice when they become kind
of big and matter and especially like uh
people can think they're having a
conversation and sometimes even from the
outside you can see like these people
are just talking completely past each
other uh and you can kind of see that
they're not really understanding each
other even though they maybe think they
are
um and so yeah I I
I don't know how I'm not brittle they
are I think they uh they I think we
think they're less brittle than maybe
they are uh I think sometimes we assume
people are understanding what we're
saying better than they actually are
because they nod and smile at us
um and uh because that's it makes us
feel good for people to understand us it
makes us good feel good to understand
other people uh but yeah I mean
it's uh any clear I mean clearly we do
have a lot in common and there's
definitely things we can understand
about each other uh but uh but yeah it's
like I do sometimes think of maybe we're
more different from each other than we
really realized
yeah that's a that's a really
fascinating thought I mean we speak a
lot with Wally tubber and he he says how
language has evolved to be extremely
ambiguous actually because it's a form
of compression so we we don't say
everything we mean and we'll get into
like language models in a minute that's
part of the reason why they don't
understand things is because a lot of
information is not in the text and while
it says that um we have a lot of um what
he calls naive physics so we understand
that objects can't be in two places at
the same time and if something is
located inside something else and we
move that thing somewhere else then the
thing inside has also moved so we're
doing all sorts of reasoning on the Fly
and what we're kind of doing is like
we're disambiguating out of the 50
meanings of an utterance into the
meaning and like it just we almost
always understand each other you know
you you wouldn't really expect that
no I mean
um
yeah it's I mean we we generally have
like I mean our understanding the
physics should generally be compatible
with each other uh I I do feel like it's
um i i in most cases yes we do very
clearly understand each other because in
most cases it's more like well-defined
um I I think you the trouble gets in
sort of like fuzzier areas uh about
people's like emotions and or opinions
about things uh where our priors are
more sort of maybe less uh less tied to
like objective things like physics and
are more sort of just tied to like our
upbringing and just sort of whatever
ideas Notions we have about how people
should like behave and interact and what
like our value systems
um and and so yeah when people are
talking about some of these things I
feel like they're more likely to be able
to like talk past each other not realize
it because they're sort of assumptions
about what is important or what is
Meaningful uh might be different from
each other
yeah actually you're absolutely right so
we don't have an objective phenomenology
and I mean I I used to do there's a
thing called Quantified Self where you
kind of like keep a diary every day and
you you record how you're feeling in
that day and feel you know feeling is a
subjective state so I remembered at the
time that every single day I needed a
new word to describe how I was feeling
because the old word I was using you
know didn't work anymore so the number
of words kept growing and actually
that's so true isn't it if I tell you
how I'm feeling right now that's
completely brittle so there are some
things in the world that are quite
informational and objective and we can
communicate very well and then when
we're bordering on anything subjective
language fails us yeah and yeah and then
we were trying to map whatever word
you're using on to how I would use that
word to describe a feeling that I would
be having and that mapping seems
completely like
without a long conversation to try to
like beat up that map in oh it could be
quite different
uh in yeah how I would apply that word
to my own feeling
yeah and there's been studies done as
well that I think um certain tribes have
completely different color perception
and there are also Concepts like
vagueness so you know what is a pile of
sand and you know what is a shade of red
and these things are actually very very
difficult to communicate objectively
yeah
um I yeah that things like color
perception are kind of the interesting
ones because it the literature is a bit
all messy on these some of these topics
um and it's it's some of it is just
where you draw the lines between colors
and then how those how those linguistic
boundaries affect perception uh there
definitely seems to be both things going
uh but it's not sort of like
I I don't think any I think it's a
strong claim to like oh the people that
can't perceive green
um or something like that
um it's just like where they would draw
the line between blue would be in a
slightly different place and then they
might kind of see them as being for they
would sort of experience them as being
like further apart or closer together
then you you would necessarily but uh
yeah not necessarily their experiences
wouldn't wouldn't necessarily be super
alien to you but they're yeah their sort
of experience of maybe more very
cultural uh
like cultural taboos or something would
be very different than yours
yeah I mean one thing you're alluding to
there is it's um when we deal with
complicated systems there's a real
problem about drawing boundaries and I
was I mean for instance a great example
he's got this idea of a Markov boundary
and and it could be at the cellular
level or it could be you as a person and
then when we talk about things like
agency and Free Will we we tend to
anthropomorphize this boundary so we
tend to think of ourselves as
individuals but actually
um you could draw boundaries at
different scales and the boundaries
might be Observer relative as well so
your boundary might not be my boundary
yeah exactly
um yeah that's
yeah there's something not something I
know I know a ton about uh but this I
yeah this how you define yourself and
how you think of yourself within the
context of your community and whatnot I
mean some of these ideas are just very
cultural and how into how you experience
yourself is probably even like very
different can be very different
cross-culturally
yeah I mean maybe one thing to bring in
is is when you're when you're um as a
Quant when you're doing modeling you you
have this very very complex system and
and you you draw boundaries and you
create variables and observables and and
you know what I mean you can't you kind
of build a model and that boundary could
exist at any scale it seems like quite a
um it's a bit of an art and a science at
the same time
yeah no for sure
um
yeah exactly that's kind of why I like
some of these uh complicated problems
that are not very well defined where you
kind of have to use intuition uh or just
to sort of do the best you can do at
sort of drawing like what are the
relevant variables what sort of a
priority makes sense to me to be the
things that matter for the system
um behaving at this uh within the
context of this experiment or the
context of this Market or whatnot uh
trying to trying to draw boundaries uh
in because the rules for these systems
are not clear like what are the all the
relevant variables for everything
um and do you have access to them and
can you control them and generally you
don't know them all and you don't
necessarily have access or can control
any of them
um and so it's yeah it's it is it is a
bit of an art
um
well now might be a good time to talk
about numeros so you're the chief
scientist and it's this insanely cool
platform right so people can go on there
they can download data sets they can
build their own models they can stake
the models I mean why don't you just
like talk me through it sure yeah so uh
we advertise ourselves as being the
hardest data science problem on the
planet uh because I I think it is
because the court like as I said the
correlations you're chasing are on the
order of like three or four percent uh
out of sample uh which is and uh so just
sort of being able to tell do you have
something real or is it just in the
noise can be extremely hard to do uh
which is and uh we we set up the problem
for participants we give out a set of
data that has been uh cleaned and uh
obfuscated and regularized and it you
basically just have a set of features
and a set of targets and you're just
trying to build models to go from
features to Target so it's sort of a
very classic machine learning style
problem
um and uh it's nicely curated for you
and uh and how it works for us is every
week people submit predictions on a new
set of features so every week we release
a new set of features and people just
run their models over those features and
give us a set of predictions and people
stake on those predictions and so people
stick our our cryptocurrency called NMR
and if their predictions do well uh they
make money and if the predictions don't
don't do well that week they can lose
money and uh and they sort of are
expressing their confidence in their
models using their stake uh and so we
basically
uh use this expression of confidence as
a way to sort of integrate this these
signals into our meta model our meta
model is really just like a stake
weighted average of all the signals
people are submitting
um and these signals these predictions
are just sort of weights on um on stocks
they're sort of like how do we want to
go long or do we want to go short in the
stock
um there's sort of just expressing do we
think a soccer is going to go down are
going to go up uh we the stake way to
model we uh feed to through our
Optimizer which is just doing a convex
optimization problem trying to create a
portfolio from the signal and uh and is
that that portfolio changes week to week
and so that uh just the difference
between the previous and the new
portfolio is just what we trade every
week and so our trading is basically
completely determined by the like
thousand people all over the world
submitting um predictions every week and
so it's this very kind of nice
decentralized uh hedge fund um where the
signal generation is a very
decentralized and we get the advantages
of ensembling over a wide variety of
models and see people are are they're
trying to make their models both uh
predict the targets very well
um and consistently and uh we have other
incentives to try to make uh predict uh
aspects of the targets that other people
are not
um to try to so that their contribution
is sort of more unique and they can make
quite a bit of money by having their
predictions be pretty different from
other people's uh but also still
accounting for like variance to the
Target
um and so uh that that system is we call
true contribution uh and it's really uh
we try to we it was our attempt to try
to
make people's predictions and pay out
more tied to actual portfolio returns
um because the sort of standard scoring
we're just doing the correlation of how
well uh your predictions match like the
new the new weekly weeks Target that is
uh determined by just how the stocks uh
move that over the course of 20 days
um the true contribution is basically
sort of doing the whole process like
creating the meta model uh running it
through the portfolio after my eyes are
getting a portfolio getting portfolio
returns and then we try to see like uh
take the gradient through all of that
until you can find out uh if People's
Stakes have been more or less would have
made more or less money and use this
this gradient of uh of the stakes with
respect to the payout with respect to
the portfolio returns as a way to uh pay
people out to essentially increase their
weight or decrease their weight and that
tends to reward people with more unique
contributions
I've got so many questions sure so um I
mean I really like this idea because
first of all you're democratizing the
whole thing and you're kind of gamifying
it and it's a meritocracy so any any
data scientist can go on there and flex
their muscles and build great models and
be recognized for doing so and even earn
money for doing so but um but in a way I
want to contrast it to somewhere like
kaggle now on kaggle I mean
traditionally data science has been
about you know understanding the domain
a lot of data science is business
analysis essentially and kind of
understanding what makes something work
in a model and as I understand with
numeride the the interface is kind of
the same so they get maybe they get
similar shape of data every time they
build the models on it and in in this
domain because you know like those
technical analysis and there's
fundamentals and they might still
understand some Market they have some
kind of extrinsic understanding of why
their model would work but but they
don't have the same kind of
understanding no yeah the the features
include all sorts of things from like
analyst sentiments um and other sort of
fundamental uh things to technical
features
um but the that is all sort of obscured
from people people just have these funny
feature names uh and so it's up to them
to just use their sort of machine
learning toolbox to figure out what are
the good features for predicting what
features tend to work well uh how do we
put combine those features uh and so we
actually wanted to kind of like remove
any of the people's biases for what
features they think will work we we
wanted to not have people's Financial
intuitions
um play into it we wanted to sort of set
it up as a pure machine learning problem
um to try to make it uh yeah basically
to make it be better than any human
could possibly be uh so this is with
this sort of combined Ensemble wisdom of
the crowd we're trying to make it like
the alphago of like Finance uh something
that is just that performs like a
superhuman level in ways you don't
really understand
interesting and um you're aggregating
the predictions together in in some way
yeah it's actually uh fairly simple we I
mean people submit uh their predictions
were which are just a number between
zero and one for every stock
um and it's basically just a rank
ordering of stock and we uh just
normalize everyone's predictions and
then just weight them by their stake and
then just average them together and to
do another read organization so that
it's the right scale and sort of
distributional shape to be fed to the
optimizer
um but uh it's a fair it's a fairly
simple and robust way to weight things
we're basically just using people's
expressed confidence in their model as
as the waiting system and uh and because
there's this feedback payments and
paying out people uh good models their
Stakes increase over time so their
weight in The Meta model increases over
time and bad models there's their
weights decrease over time so it's kind
of like a human in the loop gradient
descent if we're doing like gradient
scent with the stakes as the weights in
the model
fascinating and can you give us any
intuition on how that model is tuned and
uh you know like what kind of penalty
you're using are you using just the
stakes or also the the previous
um performance so um no we're not
actually using the previous performance
it's really just Stakes um the previous
performance only enters into the fact uh
that this good performance of the past
would have made their state grow over
time
um and but we have thousands and
thousands of models now and so any one
model uh is only a very small percentage
of the meta model
um and even the ones that are the
biggest are maybe only a couple percent
of the total meta model uh and it's it
is a sort of like power law distribution
um there is a lot of work that I've done
in the portfolio optimization set
um and that's the going from the signal
to the portfolio and there is actually a
lot that goes on in there as well uh
just in how you construct a portfolio
how you determine how much you're going
to trade each week
um and how you make your portfolio what
you make uh exposed to
um exposed really just means is uh are
the way to your portfolio correlated
with lots and lots of things and so uh
there's a lot we go uh do to try to make
the portfolio weights not correlated
with uh with the market overall so we're
a market neutral
um uh we're a market neutral hedge
funded so we try to be uncorrelated in
the market have a beta of zero so when
the market goes up or down you can't
really tell how we would do on that kind
of day
um and but we also try to be
uncorrelated to lots and lots of other
things that we think could drive returns
so uh we don't we try not to have like
uh big country biases big sector biases
uh Factor biases so Factor are things
like value and momentum these kind of
like uh more abstract quantities that
are supposed to tell you something about
uh about classes of stocks uh but we try
to be uncorrelated to basically
everything uh and they're just trying to
get the sort of pure machine learning
and non-linear uh signal that is driving
stock returns or like stock specific
Alpha uh we call it sort of like the uh
the um how well soccer is going to do
sort of just by itself not taking all
these other things that are about into
account
yeah that's really interesting and I
guess like one of the one of the
problems on kaggle is that most of the
solutions are so overfit to the to the
to the training set that they never
generalized to real-wide versions of the
problem but what you're doing actually
is to kind of like remove away a lot of
those opportunities for overfitting and
also allowing the models to be used
again when the next thing comes around
but but just quickly on on the
aggregating stuff the reason I'm
interested in that is on my PhD I did
prediction with expert advice and
there's a whole load of theoretical
approaches to that where you can have an
aggregating algorithm that produce you
know that produces performance or
um a kind of like an error bound which
is not much worse than the best path of
switching experts so if you took the
optimal path of the best expert every
single time step you can have algorithms
that have a provable approvable bound
and not much worse than that
yeah we so
we've done a lot to try to experiment
with trying to improve upon stake
waiting
um and it's always been really hard to
do it in a robust way uh it's I mean for
for one stake waiting is uh it's it's
sort of nice in that it's easy for
people to understand people are it's
very clean in how it works it sort of
fits with the ethos and the uh uh like
and the idea of the company of how how
it's distributed and decentralized and
you uh you express your confidence by
your stake
um but it but it does sort of seem like
there should be a better way to
aggregate models uh but pretty much
every time we've tried to find something
better it's
it might be a little bit better but it's
like less robust it tends to just to be
less robust uh and it's because you are
essentially just sort of fitting uh to
the past and to try to find weights of
the models or something you're it tends
to just like overfit and this sort of
stake waiting thing you can't really
overfit it's just sort of it's a a
property that just sort of evolves
um as the tournament goes on
um without ever considering like the
past performance and all these things uh
so yeah it's it's been kind of
interesting until we so we it's one of
these things we sort of revisit every
year at some point of like let's try to
build a better meta model but we usually
just come back to stick waiting in the
end yeah well in a way I mean we're
prediction with expert advice you have a
learning rate and I guess you don't even
have that problem because you're just
using the the stakes
um as yeah
um but yeah the I mean our learning rate
uh so I mean our payout system is the
way we adjust the weights over time
um and so we have done like some
simulations to show that like if how we
reward people how that affects their
weights over time and how that affects
metal model performance so you wouldn't
want to have a payout system that would
make the metal model worse over time
um and so yeah like this this true
contribution idea this gradient of the
stakes
um we did simulations to show it does
actually improve the meta model over
time
um to pay out in this way
um it's nothing I mean uh people do
things like take their Stakes out
withdraw money and so it's not a perfect
system people entering the tournament
people some people entering with a lot
of money some people enter with not that
much money
um and uh and so yeah it it takes time
for these things all to kind of shake
out in real life but the overall idea is
that we are essentially adjusting the
wage through our payouts towards this
sort of uh more optimal meta model over
time interesting so I'm I'm actually
very very interested to give it a go and
I guess like first of all you could
sketch out what the process looks like I
mean let's say I had a few hundred
dollars and I wanted to build a model
and and also it's got to be a good model
let's face it so if I if I just logged
on there and I built a gradient boosted
3 model
would that work
it would actually so
um uh I mean it's tabular data and
Terror data is very minimal to gradient
boosted trees uh we have a lot of
example models that we have uh put up
and they're doing quite well uh so um
the the basically all you have to do is
you can go to the website uh and just
download a big zip file that includes
all the data uh in it's uh in parquet
and then you can just open it up in uh
in in Python and fit a gradient with the
tree and we have example scripts sort of
showing this along with some more
interesting types of pre-processing and
other sort of uh ideas like feature
neutralization
um
which I can talk about in a second uh
but yeah a lot of a lot of our sort of
standard internal models use basically
gradient boosted trees
um and we are I mean we have uh
basically example models running that
and they all have positive correlation
with uh and true and and still true
contributions so they're actually
working out of sample and Performing
quite well
um that that hasn't all been sort of
eaten up by people using similar enough
models
um there's a lot of opportunity to make
sort of unique models too because once
something that's sort of unique about
our tournament is we release actually
several targets release like 20
something targets
um and then and they're all constructed
in somewhat slightly different ways and
so and you can find that uh if you train
on a different Target it might work
almost as well as trading on the Target
that you're scored on
um and it might all say Ensemble really
well with a model trained on different
targets and so you can actually create
an ensembles fairly easily just by
training on different targets uh because
yeah it's it's it is kind of remarkable
that a model trained on a different
Target can actually work better on the
target you're interested in uh but that
kind of thing yeah definitely does
happen I mean part of it's called all
the correlations are so low but some
targets might just sort of have a better
property in uh making your model pick up
on the actual signal that you want to
model rather than sort of variance that
is like not that you don't want to model
interesting I I think one of the one of
the issues is you might not know what
models that people are using but I
wondered if you did have any intuition
I'd be fascinated to know are they using
very complex models are they using
simple models
uh from talking to participants there's
a huge range uh there are some people
using like extremely simple trees there
are some people who are using incredibly
elaborate neural networks uh with very
sort of custom architectures
um that are sort of designed to the
problem
um there yeah there's a whole huge right
I mean there's people have huge
ensembles there's people who are doing
kind of like online learning where their
model is actually using the features
that we release uh that week and sort of
uh using that in some sort of
unsupervised learning
um to sort and then so it takes some
while from when we release they can't
just like run their model through the
new set of features they have to
incorporate their new set of features in
this unsupervised way before they can
um so yeah there's a incredible variety
of techniques people are using
fascinating and how how big is this
parquet for how many rows how many
um uh you know fields and are they all
just real numbers between note and one
so yeah so it's um there's uh how many
features are we up to now we have a
couple thousand features roughly and
there's a few million a couple million
rows I think
um it's so one sort of uh additional
piece of structure in the data is
there's these things called arrows and
the arrows are essentially just the
weeks
um and because this the competition has
this structure of we're making
predictions every week and So within
each era there's like say 5 000 uh rows
which are basically like 5 000 stocks
um and so uh one sort of interesting
thing is you are you want your model to
be good across eras not necessarily
across samples
um and since it creates a different
structure in how you think about the
problem because you want your model to
be consistently good in every era uh and
that can give you a different solution
than if you just try to say maximize
some Metric over the whole training set
um which is it yeah kind of uh yeah uh
but
um but yeah it is basically just a big
parquet file uh we do divide uh it into
like training and um uh like there's a
uh like a testing set
um
but uh it's yeah it's
do you have specific questions about how
that is organized
well and again I'm really interested
because on my PhD I I did a whole bunch
of um prediction models on financial
data sets I was predicting like the
implied volatility of the blackshells
formula and some you know some future
Futures data but but and my big thing at
the time was I was fascinated by regimes
in financial data and you get these you
get these changing dependencies with
time and what I did I mean you could
actually visualize it if you if you
build a load of
um expert models on different regimes
and then you get them to predict on the
other regimes data you get this kind of
self-similarity Matrix and and it looks
like you get this kind of structure in
there because there are certain regimes
where this particular model actually
predicts quite far out into the future
and then it might suddenly go dead so
you get these kind of squares and and I
had this big thesis that if I have
expert models and use prediction with
expert advice then when we come into a
new regime I would quickly learn which
experts are are the good ones and I had
this thesis that sometimes old
information is very helpful in the
future more so than using like a simple
sliding window Ridge regression or
whatever and it turned out I was wrong
it's almost always better just use a
sliding window regression but um but
yeah it's fascinating it's um it's yeah
it's it's interesting like the uh but
you definitely want to train on a lot of
data for the for these models
um it definitely like if you just use
the prior one year of data your models
are gonna be pretty crap
um it definitely helps to use like prior
10 years of data uh and so uh and so it
is you're using actually quite old data
often in predicting uh into the future
but uh generally yeah if you were only
just using the last year or two of data
your models are gonna I paid quite a
hard time
um yeah one other thing about the
features I wanted to say is they are
between zero and one they're in five
bins they're
0.25.5.75 and one uh so the data has
been like been
um in this way and the targets are also
binned
um in this same sort of bins but with a
different distribution the targets have
like in their extreme bins only like
five percent of the values in the next
six the next two extreme bins
um like uh what is it uh
uh 20 in each of them and then 50 as a
zero
um interesting uh but the all the
features are basically just uh 20 in
each of the bins
um and so the the bidding is a pretty
strong form of regularization uh it sort
of prevents you from like a tree from
splitting sort of any arbitrary place
you or can only split at these things
and so that kind of forces at least some
of the space to be uh at different
splits and the regularization it's kind
of you would think that uh having
continuous features would be a lot
really helpful but I mean it's really
not uh it's kind of remarkable how how
how lossy some of these transforms are
that we do that actually seem to be
helpful
yeah it's so interesting and um I guess
like one thing I didn't really
appreciate at the time is you know we
were just talking about these um complex
dynamical systems like the brain or like
financial markets and there's of course
the market efficiency hypothesis and
um you know perhaps one of the reasons
why old information might not be Salient
is because if the underlying system is
actually taking a trajectory through
this kind of complex space then you
might argue that almost regardless of
where you Traverse you'll always be in a
novel situation and then there's this
Continuum of regularity versus chaos so
this like for example if you're
predicting um options Futures when they
get close to maturity the volatility
just goes crazy and they just become
increasingly unpredictable and I guess
the the art in this kind of data is
knowing when you're in a regime which
has some regularity and and when you're
not it's Yeah It's tricky because like
ideally we want our ma we want our meta
model to sort of work well in any regime
and
um and it does seem to work pretty well
consistently and but what you do find on
like the leaderboard uh tournament
participants you'll see some people who
stay at the top of the leaderboard for
weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks then
suddenly preciply fall uh fall like down
the leaderboard
um as demonstrating some sort of regime
effects
um one really kind of interesting thing
I did was uh I fit like a mixture of
linear models to the data
um so if you fit just like a mixture of
two linear models where it's sort of
selecting which arrows to use for which
of the two linear models uh you
basically uh one linear model will get
about 60 of the errors one will get
about 40 of the arrows and their weights
will be almost mere images of each other
um
and this just comes out like that is the
optimal fit for rough for 40 of the
arrows it's basically completely the
opposite of the other arrows
um which yeah demonstrating some like
that's why I'm like markets are
extremely hard because like something
that works well a lot of the time it
suddenly it just works really absolutely
horribly
um and so you're often trying to split
this difference of find something that
doesn't work super well at one time and
then we'll like crater at another time
that's the meta model wants to kind of
work really like pretty good all the
time
um and that's one of the things ensembly
and all these models that maybe even the
individual models probably have a lot
more regime characteristics than this
overall meta model
I wondered whether folks were using some
really esoteric approaches I mean I'm
interested in geometric deep learning
and algorithmic reasoning and you know
even things like ESO esoteric options
like um cellular automata
um do you see anything like that getting
traction or maybe even discrete program
synthesis
um I don't I don't know because yeah
like uh I only see what people are
willing to post and share on forums and
there's quite a bit of sharing on our
forums of information but uh there's
definitely some people at the top of the
leaderboards who are doing something
that's working quite well for them for
quite a long time uh that they haven't
shared improved
um and so it's it's I'm not even sure
what all the people are doing but there
are uh there's some I mean people allude
to using like uh like tricks I mean
um that they've learned in different
jobs I mean we have some people uh with
like a variety of backgrounds it's been
really cool to like see this community
grow and how people who are like
astrophysicists particle physicists
um people who are doing like a
uh like computer vision
um and whatever sort of techniques
they've learned in their different
fields and try to use them on this
problem that was what sort of attracted
me as like I was doing like
conversational neuroscience and uh I saw
this problem I was like oh this is a
complete free playground you can do
whatever you want and so it's a fun
opportunity to try out ideas that
wouldn't really work well in
computational neuroscience
yeah indeed and uh physics I mean the
The Road to Reality by Roger Penrose
um I think it was Michael bronstein who
said that if you could summarize the
entire book in one word it would be
Symmetry and uh there's also another key
idea from a lot of researchers which is
abstraction you know which is like some
meta property of of the relationship
between data so you know you probably
have lots of folks coming in from
different fields and they have some very
very interesting approaches to solving
these problems
yeah for sure
um yeah I mean I I have I mean there's
people who've used some like interesting
like Auto encoders to try to learn
structure from data as a way to learn
features
um people using it's interesting
non-linear non-linear dimensionality
reduction techniques to try to uh yet to
try to find various features
um
it's uh and yeah even uh so some things
people do so some sort of interesting
feature selection or denoising types of
things
um that they've learned in their fields
um
yeah yeah it's it's always interesting
to me to see like how different fields
uh that use machine learning use it in
different ways and what sort of tricks
and tips might cross over
I was going to ask about that because
you have um loads and loads of features
and there's this problem called the
cursor of dimensionality right so you
know when when when the uh when the
number of Dimensions increases the
volume of the space increases
exponentially which means like this
concept of nearness basically disappears
and there's statistical models don't
work anymore so you know presumably
people would do things like I don't know
yeah dimensionality reduction feature
selection that I mean neural networks
are quite clever in in the sense that
they via a variety of methods overcome
the curse of dimensionality by learning
some data manifold or whatever but you
know it's it's it's with natural data
it's not with financial data so it's not
a given it's yeah and that this is
actually one of the things that
um was really intriguing to me when I
started in finances so in in science
when you're doing regressions you're
trying to find often sparse Solutions
you're trying to find the sort of small
number of variables predict your target
to try to find whatever sort of maybe
causal relationships there are
um in in finance where we often try to
do exactly the opposite uh where we want
our models to carry about care about all
the features a little bit uh and so we
do we'll do something like uh uh what we
call it feature neutralization where
basically you take your prediction take
the linear model of your prediction from
the features and subtract it off and so
you're making your prediction not
linearly correlated or linearly
dependent on any of your features um or
doing some fraction of that so just
trying to remove too strong of a linear
relationship between a feature and your
prediction
um and you do other regularization
techniques like in your tree learning to
uh maybe uh one thing that works quite
well is using like column sample by tree
let's add it to a very low value so each
tree is only considering a small subset
of features and so your Ensemble is sort
of you uses a lot of the different
features uh because it's sort of each
tree it only has access to 10 of the
features uh across the whole ensemble
you are probably using a lot of your
features a little bit
um and that tends to work quite well and
the re I mean the reason is uh it's
because like features will work for a
while and then they'll just turn around
on you and so you don't want to be sort
of super dependent on any one feature
um and so yeah it does make the curse of
dimensionality kind of worse in some
ways because you uh you don't want
enough to find necessarily find just a
small subset of variables that uh are
the best because sometimes that will
maybe give you a really good model for a
while but sometimes all of a sudden
those will just turn around on you and
then your model just like is almost
anti-correl with what it should be yeah
it's so interesting you know like this
problem with the changing dependencies
so essentially you're modeling a
non-stationary process which makes it
much harder and when I was speaking with
um Sarah hooker the other day she was
talking about fairness and bison models
and and part of the problem there is you
know we we optimize for headline metrics
like accuracy and when you decompose the
training set into let's say different
categories like men and women and people
who live in London
um the accuracy is is very stratified it
might perform very badly for people that
live in London but very good for people
that live in New York you know and then
you start getting into the situation and
saying okay well I'll build an ensemble
of models that are you know
independently optimized for all the
different things but then you have this
impedance mismatch between This Global
you know accuracy that that you that you
were optimizing for and are on the
benchmarks
yeah no that's a it's a really
interesting property of these things is
um yeah especially classification models
where they will work well for some
categories and not others and it can be
sort of tricky to find out why
um it's like what are those features
just more discriminative or are like are
these classes somehow harder to tell
apart just in some way
um it's yeah it's uh
I'm glad people are starting to like
look at and to try to dig into some of
these like details rather than just
looking at headline metrics and I'm also
sort of happy that the field is sort of
moving to like this out of distribution
learning uh is becoming a much more uh
interesting topic because like that is
what really matters in making machine
learning that is going to affect the
real world is need to work out of
distribution out of your sort of
training and test that split
distribution
um as well as possible and like how you
do that is I mean so very much an open
question clearly uh and the how well you
could potentially do that is even still
an open question
um but that is one of the uh I mean that
is sort of what true intelligence is to
somebody like humans are pretty good at
adapting outer distribution
um and uh what is it about us what are
like how are we able to do that and how
do we make our sort of machine learning
systems work better that way how are we
sort of able to
I mean yeah I think it probably has
something to do with we're able to learn
sort of causal structures that work well
um and and the distribution can be very
different but the sort of causal
structurals uh remain
um and we're able to somehow infer that
causal structures from data uh from just
our sins State and uh World models
um
but yeah basically the question is how
do we make our machine Learning Systems
be able to do like similar sorts of
things
uh yeah this has been absolutely amazing
uh do you have any any final thoughts
where can people find out more
information about you Michael
um so let's see uh well so I want to
point people first to just like numerai
uh numer.ai is the website
um I am fairly active in the forums and
the the rocket chat we have which is
sort of just our own personal uh chat uh
chat service
um for a tournament participants to
communicate with each other and I
occasionally like posts on the forums
there
um that's probably the best way to like
get in contact is just message me on the
on on Rocket chat
um and uh yeah so
um that's yeah that's probably the best
way to uh get in contact uh my also my
email is mdo at numer.ai
um and uh I would yeah I really love if
people come uh check out the tournament
um give feedback and start participating
um I've yeah I I found it it was a lot
of fun
um as a participant
um and uh yeah I joined the company
partly so I was starting to make more
money at doing the tournament than I was
at my job in science
um and so yeah I mean it's a pretty fun
like hobby inside gig and potentially
even quite lucrative
amazing well um Dr Michael Oliver it's
been an absolute honor thank you so much
for joining us this evening
thanks so much for having you it's been
so much fun